[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous c'est un immense plaisir
d'être ici avec vous aujourd'hui
beaucoup d'émotion aussi et pour
terminer cette belle journée toute
particulière je m'appelle axe élevé car
les je vais aujourd'hui vous raconter
l'une de mes plus belles aventures
je dis souvent que jusqu'à l'âge de 16
ans je me suis laisser vivre j'étais ce
jeune garçon aux cheveux blonds myope
astigmate et hypermétropes mais tout de
même très gâté je vais en lycée à lyon
dans les monts d'or entouré d'une
famille exceptionnelle et d'amis
incroyable dont certains sont encore
aujourd'hui comme des frères et soeurs à
l'école je n'étais pas au travail plutôt
même parmi les derniers classés au
bonnet à zéro à chaque dictée c'est pas
drôle
au collège je passe de la 6e à la 5e
avec 9 5 de moyenne
même schéma de la 5ème à la 4ème et je
redouble forcément ma quatrième avec 9 9
de moyenne
une sale affaire ça non plus c'est pas
drôle lorsqu'arrive l'été 2007 juste
avant mon entrée au lycée chaque année
et depuis mon plus jeune âge j'avais la
chance de voyager aux quatre coins du
monde de l'afrique à l'asie en passant
par les plus belles villes de la planète
cette année là nous partout entre les
etats-unis et le canada jusqu'à la
frontière avec l'alaska dans le grand
nord ouest
un voyage sublime mais c'est pendant ce
voyage même que démarre à la plus
éprouvante de mes expériences mais aussi
la plus enrichissante de mésaventure
celle que pourtant aujourd'hui je ne
souhaite à personne
c'est là bas que je ressens qui ses
premiers mots de tête et c'est à ce
moment là que j'ai commencé à me
ressentir vivre à prendre le temps et la
conscience ne meurent sentir vibrer au
plus profond de moi lorsque cette simple
douleur se transformer rapidement une
réelle souffrance
cette sensation qui prend le dessus sur
tout qui devient omniprésente de jour
comme de nuit
j'allais embarqué pour cette périlleuse
aventure d'environ 3 ans dont le seul
objectif était de rester en vie environ
trois mois après ses premiers mots de
tête ressenti au canada on découvrit que
j'étais atteint d'une tumeur au cerveau
ce jour là j'allais vivre le moment le
plus atroce des trois années à venir
le regard de ma maman lors de l' annonce
rempli de cette peur de voir son fils
mourir dans cette petite pièce où je me
rhabille et après avoir passé mon irm
environ cinq mètres carrés de tabouret
un porte manteau et un poster expliquant
ce qu'était une irm
le radiologue entre à son petit stylo
dans la poche et s'adresse à ma maman
votre fils est atteint d'une tumeur au
cerveau à ce moment là tout s'est arrêté
il ne restait plus que la souffrance et
la peur chaque jour je partais un peu
plus je me sentais m'éloigner à chaque
clignements de paupières très vite j'ai
quitté l'école pour découvrir un tout
autre monde
le monde hospitalier la dépendance
totale pour manger pour respirer pour
faire mes besoins ou simplement veiller
sur mon coeur la peur de s'endormir le
soir ou de ne pas se réveiller le
lendemain alors qu'il faut se battre
dans sa chambre les gémissements
d'autres passants qui résonne dans le
couloir la puissance d'un sourire aussi
est le récit d'un regard la souffrance
quotidienne et ce combat de chaque
instant je grandissais d'épreuve en
épreuve
opéré d'un poumon du coeur et deux fois
du cerveau ou encore l'atmosphère
épouvantable des soins intensifs
un jour il fallu aller chercher cette
humeur au beau milieu de mon cerveau
chose que l'on essayé d'éviter depuis
plus d'un an
car cette opération est une folie mais
je mourrai et c'était la dernière chance
de m'en sortir
c'est ainsi que le 13 octobre 2009 je
partis à l'aube ils étaient à peine 5
heures du matin en direction du bloc
opératoire
l'avant veille mon chirurgien était
passé dans ma chambre tard le soir
j'étais branché de partout et debout
devant mon lit une expliqué que dans
deux jours on viendrait me chercher très
tôt pour me conduire vers le bloc et que
et surtout que je devais savoir que je
reviendrai sûrement différent de cette
opération il ya ce moment là à tout
juste 17 ans je lui ai simplement
demandé s'il avait le temps de faire de
la moto
sa passion alors qu'ils étaient là jour
et nuit
après 9 heures d'opération où mon
chirurgien tenter d'aller chercher cette
chose au milieu des deux hémisphères de
mon cerveau j'allais vivre le réveil de
ma vie ce nouveau départ aussi effrayant
que libérateur
cette nouvelle expédition pour me
reconstruire et à trie si aujourd'hui
avec vous et en pleine forme
j'étais sorti d'affaires mais différent
en salle de réveil
la vision encore troubles c'était un
tout nouveau ressenti de moi je ne
souffrais plus mais le sentez cette
grande cicatrice derrière mon crâne qui
respirait je découvrais le monde en
voyant double le menton coller à la
poitrine
je ne savais plus tenir debout et
j'avais perdu la mémoire à court terme
j'étais de retour à la vie mais devant
une nouvelle immense montagne je
démarrais ainsi dans ma chambre
d'hôpital ce nouveau périple celui de la
reconstruction
partagé entre le plaisir de contempler
chaque matin la lumière du soleil levant
et de me dire que j'aurais peut-être
mieux fait d'y rester que c'était de la
folie
car je ne savais pas où j'allais si
j'allais retrouver cette mémoire si
j'allais pouvoir remarcher continuer à
joueur au tennis un jour conduire ou
simplement me servir un verre d'eau je
repris ainsi progressivement du plaisir
dans ma chambre à recevoir de la visite
d'amis et de ma famille chaque jour un
médecin me lever pour me faire faire un
aller retour du grand couloir en
marchant pour retrouver l'équilibré et
mettre mes pieds l'un devant l'autre
ce même médecin me disais aussi et la
petite infirmière asiatiques la super
mignonne non mais chaque chose en son
temps
chaque soir une infirmière de peau noire
est plutôt ronde venait dans ma chambre
pour me masser nous l'entendions arriver
avant même de l'avoir grâce aux de la
crème qu'elle mettait dans sa main en
arrivant à de leur tournée alors comme
une crêpe pour me masser violemment
pendant dix secondes avant de me
regarder satisfaites les mains posées
sur les hanches sa partie d'une
tellement bonnes intentions mais
j'appréhende et chacune de ses visites
pour le plus grand rire de ma famille et
de mes amis
chaque soir aussi un peu plus tard cette
fameuse infirmières asiatiques venaient
s'asseoir au bout de mon lit pour
discuter parfois pendant une heure avant
de rentrer chez elle
alors qu'elle avait un filet par-dessus
sa blouse blanche sa doudoune noire
et c'est hier max noire des moments
pleins de huy mais un jour précis a tout
changé ma vie tout entière
lorsque quelques semaines plus tard je
suis sorti de l'hôpital du tonkin sur un
siège roulant poussé par ma maman au
rez-de-chaussée du bâtiment
les portes sont ouvertes nous avancions
et je ressentis sur mes joues je
ressentis sur mes joues le vent se poser
j'avais oublié cette sensation ce
bonheur inestimable et pourtant si
simple
je pleurais d'émotion le chemin est
encore long mais je sentais sur mes
joues ce frisson de me sentir vivre et
c'est ce message là que j'aimerais vous
offrir aujourd'hui que chacun d'entre
vous prennent le temps en sortant d'ici
de se ressentir vivre aujourd'hui tous
ces souvenirs toutes ses images ses
sensations ses peurs aussi font partie
de mon quotidien c'est pourquoi j'ai dû
transformer toutes ces choses noires
pour en faire une vraie force pour moi
comme pour le monde qui m'entoure je
suis notamment passé par l'écriture
le fait de tout poser noir sur blanc fut
une réelle thérapie j'ai aussi fait la
rencontre d'un incroyable d'un
spécialiste de l'hypnose qui me fit non
seulement miraculeusement retrouvé la
mémoire et qui m'aide à prendre du recul
avec tout ce vécu il appelait ça le
lâcher prise
en travaillant sur mon inconscient et
c'est inconscient la représente quelque
chose d'incroyable je sais encore que
pendant quelques années je devrais faire
face à un risque élevé de rechute mais
je suis persuadé et me le répète chaque
jour que je n'y retournerai pas c'est
grâce à ce travail quotidien à cette
écoute et ceux ressentis de moi que j'ai
réussi aujourd'hui être aligné je sais
ce dont j'ai besoin pour être heureux
ce que j'ai à offrir au monde est ce que
je veux faire de ma vie j'ai d'ailleurs
travaillé cette année pour l'entreprise
tic est forte chez ge dont la mission
est de lutter contre le gâchis de
talents en permettant à chacun de
s'impliquer pour construire un monde
meilleur
ceci notamment grâce à son processus
pédagogique en trois étapes inspiration
introspection et passage à l'action
cette seconde étape d'introspection
permettent à chacun de travailler sur
soi de s'écouter et de se comprend
non car il n'y a pas besoin de passer
par la maladie ou toute autre épreuve
pour prendre ce nouveau départ nous
sommes tous riche d'un parcours d'une
sensibilité de talent et de rêve toutes
ces choses nous permettant à chacun
d'entre nous décrire la plus belle de
nos histoires
alors pour répondre à cette belle
question qui nous aura accompagnés cet
après midi ah oui grille est est ce que
nous sommes arrivés
j'ose espérer que non car la vie est à
la fois tellement belle et terriblement
fragile alors ne perdons pas une seconde
pour la ressentir au plus profond de
nous et pour partager au monde qui nous
entoure ce que l'on a de meilleur en
nous car le plus beau reste à venir
merci à tous
[Musique]